[موسيقى]
طبعا على مستوى الموسيقى حكينا عن
الموسيقى ولكن الذي يعني
يجذبك في الموسيقى يعني هي
اي مناخات المناخات العربي المقامات
الموسيقيه العربيه ام الاشكال الاخرى من
الموسيقى العالميه من الاوبرا او الموسيقى
الكلاسيكيه
السوناتا
اما ربما الحروفيات والشغل والحرف هو اقرب
الى
الزائقه السمعي العربيه بشكل عام هو فعلا
هو
اقربائقه العربيه هو
مثلجاز يعني
خط الثلث لانه الراس في ارباع صوت وفي قيم
جزله بالبناء الموسيقي فهذا يطلع مع خط
الثلث بينما النهونت اوصاف الاصوات هذا
يروح مع خط الديوان الجلي في انسيابيات
وفي اشياء حلوه مثلا الخط التعليق او
الفارسه تسميه
ركيكه هو التعليق يذهب مع مقام الحجاز
مقام روحاني سلس سهل فلما ترى خط التعليق
هكذا لما تتجه للسيجا السيجا بنوعيه يعني
كان ايقاعي ولا خفيف فتشوفون يتجلى بشكل
قطعي يذهب مع الخط السنبلي
وفي ايقاع ايضا في ايقاع بلبنان كيف
يعملوا فيه معظم الاغاني الجبليه
والايقاعيه
فيعني هذا الكيف
شوي مقاربات يعني
لها دور لكن انا لا توقف عند الموسيقى
العربيه لانه الحرف برهان مفتوح يعني وليس
ان المفروض اثبت شيء لكن امانه بشكل
تلقائي يتم هذا التفاعل لانه مرتبط
بالذاكره السماعيه المبنيه على المقامات
العربيه خاصه انت يبدو تعرف فينا